in just two days the highly anticipated
resorts world will open on the las vegas
strip this complex houses three
different resorts as well as pools
entertainment
lovely restaurants and gaming kate
houston is live outside resorts world to
break down what sets each of the
properties apart
kate yes right across the street here
where you get a really good view of
the hilton conrad and crockford's and
while they're all in the same area the
experiences will be distinctly different
much of that's going to come down to
price point and a wide variety of
amenities
we're looking forward to just like
exploring it and checking it out
visitors on the las vegas strip excited
for the first
new property in more than a decade to
have something comparable will be fun
kind of to explore different areas rates
this weekend for a one bedroom for two
adults at the hilton and conrad are
varying between 460 to 560 dollars a
night
midweek is in the 130 range crockfords
says unavailable with some basic rooms
opening mid july that's not actually not
too bad considering some of the other
places that we've checked out on the
strip that's really reasonable
so what's the difference between the
three the hilton will offer classic
amenities and various city and strip
views
the conrad is accessible luxury with a
private reception lobby
and vip check-in both offer rooms and
suites
crockford's offers ultra luxury with
villas and
palaces as well as priority access to
restaurant options
people are able to choose which kind of
experience they want
and are willing to pay the premium or
the price that's affiliated with the
amenities that come with it
gary steffen with hilton says while each
resort is different from each other
combining them under one roof can
introduce visitors to each experience
and may impact where they stay for their
next visit
i think that you're going to see that
where people are going to stay maybe at
the hilton the first time and then
they're going to say wow
let's experience the conrad and that's
how we look at it when we combine
the brands in such an impressive
resort like this back out here live
rates do start to drop slightly after
the fourth of july for all three
properties in resorts world
with many weekends in the 300 dollar
range
prices were not available for those
villas and palaces
guests will need to call crawford's to
book those rooms reporting live near
resorts world tonight kate houston 8
news now